those needles were so long and they were
in my body for probably about three
months like some of them were you you
just couldn't get them out how do you
get them earned from listening to these
two folks that it's okay
to almost die as long as you don't ruin
the tape
but i don't think that was for anything
right
oh oh
you're still looking at him
just wearing a pair of underpants in a
giant is
call that that
pants it's duct tape actually we just
need a duct tape thong you made a duct
tape tongue which is painful enough and
your whole body is flung into why are
you wearing a helmet i don't understand
the helmet
for safety safety
and this was for what
that was just for online we see we just
did that for a video just for fun i love
that you get dropped naked wrapped in oh
i'm gonna get taking a phone call
let me see what this is
oh wait are you gonna do you wanna
facetime
do you wanna
just record
just record your screen dad screen
record screen record
but he's not face timing oh then yeah
should i facetime yeah phone back
facetime
okay i got my mask on at the airport
okay it's good
i don't know who that is
okay
uh anyway um
i think we're getting calls because
they're listening to it live live yeah
but but uh the the thing is that uh oh
here it is
here we go hang on one second
um let me record there we go
recording
oh wow look who it is
oh wow
hi
hey guys how's it going um
i hate to be the bear or bad news but
you guys aren't supposed to be doing
that show right now like i just did
howard stern this morning
and there's an embargo on
like video shows
and
and podcasts so like your your guys are
boning this didn't paramount tell you
no
no that's johnny knocks donna shawna
just called me
and she's freaking out because you guys
aren't supposed to be
be there and doing that
and howie like howard is going to [ __ ]
you know who's your producer
um caroline caroline
caroline shawna talked to you this
morning and told you like this is a
no-go so i don't know what's going on
but well we couldn't we couldn't find
guests last minute so
what the [ __ ] is going on right now [ __ ]
i'm like i'm on i'm getting on a plane
to vegas and i have to deal with this
[ __ ] like i have to go but you guys are
a really bonus you got to end the show
you got it you got to stop okay i got to
[ __ ] go how i'm not very sorry you or
your producer i'm sorry joe okay i got
to [ __ ] go all right
what the [ __ ] is going on dude
wait did you not prove this with
paramount zack oh my [ __ ] god dude
what the [ __ ] is going on
am i just getting pranked again right
now i feel like they're pranking us
again but i also don't know how to
[ __ ] leave dude i don't know what the
[ __ ] going on like
uh
let me help you okay maybe not
you know zach
zack it's a prank that's a prank
there's no way
they did this they did this to zach one
time i was like
how do you keep falling for it sit down
dude i started sweating on my on my
upper lip like there's sweat
i've never seen knoxville mad like that
before
and it was worse than my dad being mad
at me i'm gonna call i'm
[Music]
they fell for it big time uh zach zack
walked out of the room he can hear you
he can hear you
i walked out
i was like what the [ __ ] is going on
right now he walked out oh my god he
walked out but i'm his ride
rachel's like i'm getting the press no
matter what
i'm staying here i need the followers oh
my god
knoxville
knoxville you are the best
even before these guys got here i love
your movies i love you buddy you are
funny i can't wait for this one i know
february 4th and uh i don't know how
long it's going to take zach to recover
right here but
i love how rachel just threw it on him
right away this is your fault
come on
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
have a great flight
okay thanks guys bye bye you want to
scare me get people mad at me
not really you didn't leave i didn't but
i started sweating because i didn't know
i just like liquid just started forming
a liquid liquid started forming
you know i didn't tell even caroline i
didn't tell anybody here that i was
doing that and
second time
[Music]
you